game of the year it is never an easy
decision to make as there is a lot of
good games that came out this year
but one in particular pushed the medium
forward and is extraordinary enough
for us at gamespot to make it the game
of the year
that game is half-life alex
hey wait wait
[Music]
we know this is not a game that anyone
can play right now because
of hardware limitations stuff that some
of us here at gamespot
just have a privilege to be able to use
ultimately
access did play a part in the debates
for game of the year but
also quality and innovation does as well
and alex delivers in bucket loads
so to start peeling back the layers on
all this
we are being joined with jake decker and
michael hym to talk this whole thing out
yo dudes what's shaking
so to kick this conversation off jake
i'm going to throw it to you because
michael you actually review the game
so you did yeah so you had your moment
but we'll get to you in just a second so
jake give me
your elevator pitch as to why this game
is so important
i mean half-life alex does what
half-life games do
it pushes the medium forward in new and
interesting ways and usually the
foundation is built around tech
half-life 2 for example had the whole
physics engine
which elevated that game and this does
something similar with vr
but you know it's not just a gimmicky vr
game it takes
all of these different aspects and
brings them into one game and it does
most of that if not all to you know near
perfection at least
as what we can expect with vr tech as of
now to that point
as somebody who played you know this is
my first vr experience and someone who's
also familiar with the half-life
franchise
uh it didn't just deliver as a half-life
game
but it completely warped my perception
of vr which we'll get into
later but michael it's europe tell me
about it
cool man as jake said that uh half-life
has a history of
of you know being groundbreaking and uh
the half-life alex does just that like i
played a lot of vr games and i'm also
a long-time half-life fan i've been
there since the first game
and uh you know expectations are high
and you go into this thinking like
how is how can half-life exist in 2020
after 13 years since episode two
like the franchise to many of us has
kind of laying dormant
and but if it were to come back you know
the expectations are high what can it
possibly do and it brings
so many elements that we've seen from
different vr games some that have done
him
extremely well like reloading a gun
puzzles
movement uh and horror action it brings
all of those things together in one full
game
those are things that half-life has
always done too i remember
going through ravenholm and in half-life
2 and just being absolutely
like scared of what could possibly
happen next you get that in this game
and the
the wild fire fights that you get into
and then the the physics puzzles and
playing around with physics it's all
there but
it's not just the fact that we have a
new half-life game
at this level of quality that pushes
video games forward
but it also pushes half-life as a
franchise narratively
in some some very unexpected directions
that
that fans are that we can really get
behind
and that that kind of reinvigorates our
passion for the franchise
i think like you know there's so many
points to make michael that you just
said too and i think one of the
like the first one of the most obvious
things is that this is a franchise that
was seemingly
dead like it's it was kind of like this
this unbelievable wish that we would
ever get a follow-up to half-life 2 let
alone half-life 2
episode 2's ending and of course
like we all had our like at least i
personally was quite skeptical of the
idea of them coming back
let alone in vr and even furthermore
like a prequel
at least on surface level to some degree
but yeah
the game not just like
completely uh follows up on its ability
to like
reassert itself as one of the most
important franchises in the medium
but on its own mirror aside from it
being a half-life thing is just
it's unadulterated game design is the
best way i can kind of put it and like
how you mentioned like
this transit like half-life one and two
has always had a way of transitioning
into from horror to action to puzzle
solving to environmental storytelling
but this one
alex specifically it's ravenholm
throughout the entire game like that
game interlaces horror
and terrifying moments within these
blinks of going into a gunfight with
with a with a combine or solving a
puzzle and then suddenly being thrusted
right back into a dark pit with nothing
but a flashlight and a shotgun to fight
an enemy you've never even seen before
four shells left
you're never patronized like that game
is always perfectly leading you along
without ever actually having to tell you
anything but everything you do is
instinctual
and that i think also is a testament to
the fact that vr
the way they handle vr is just immersion
times a hundred
for you jake you said something really
amazing where it was uh it breathed life
into vr for you and for someone like me
who's like not that experienced with vr
like i this kind i feel like this dorks
my experience of the entire medium going
forward but like
jake elaborate on that yeah i mean i
will say it's very hard to play vr games
that aren't half-life alex
i picked up a quest a while ago and i
used it to play half-life alex ran great
but ever since then i've had a lot of
trouble going back to different vr games
but i i think like the big thing that
really stands out
and you mentioned it too with how the
how the game is designed all the puzzles
and whatnot but it really makes you
rethink how you play video games which
sounds really dumb when i say that but i
mean that's the name it makes sense dude
i i know right but like when you
actually get hands on it
it's interesting because like normally
there's a button to throw a grenade
right but in this
it's more you you pull the pin and
you're not just chucking it you can kind
of determine like there are areas where
you're just above enemies and you drop
the grenade on them or you try to throw
a grenade through a vent
in order to open up a door or clear out
some rubble and even it comes down to
reloading right like
i've had issues where i've grabbed a
magazine out of my backpack and put it
in and then
accidentally hit the eject button and
then i'm on the floor
trying to find my magazine so i can put
it back in before an enemy gets to me
and that's just something that
you know i've played a lot of shooters
i've played a ton of video games but
that is an experience that
has never happened before and can only
be done in vr
yeah and like it it's so hard
to describe like how pulse-pounding
those moments and those sensations are
and it's something that just
just cannot be matched with other
shooters
i mean it like the game it's like it
reconditions you
in in so many ways on when you're
like for me like first starting that
opening segment of the game
and like the first time i wish you could
pick a marker up and right on the window
like we've all seen it like it's like
it's just
it's within the five you know the
opening five minutes of the game but
it's like it's moments like that
that it rewires it rewires your brain it
that moment not like for me it wasn't
reloading a gun that really like
blew me away although it did but like
being able to write on a window with a
marker
it it completely set the tone it's set
yeah it basically sets the language of
the game you're about to experience from
that point on
even all the way down to loading your
god which again like fumbling around or
even the fact that like every single
bullet actually counts
because if you eject a clip you lose the
ammunition that's in that clip and it
makes you think about gunfights and how
you're interacting with things all much
differently
i want to kind of pivot you know we've
talked a lot about how this game
can't be half-life alex without it being
in vr
but it's important to address you know
that there is a barrier to entry with
this game in many ways
and it's beyond just hardware too it's
you know it's a lot for a lot of
people's motion sickness for a lot of
people it's the it's like the physical
ability to actually like put yourself
into this
to the scenario and like that's
something i kind of want to touch on
real quick because
you know half-life alex is doing a lot
for vr as a medium it's doing a lot in
my opinion just
in reminding people what amazing point a
to point b game design is
but there's also a lot of things that
this game does in vr for accessibility
for people who
might not have the space they think they
need or motion sickness that's helping
it a lot
so like that's just some of the stuff i
want to talk about because we've all
lived in different scenarios
all three of us who played this game
like jake what was that like for you
like what did you use to play it
and what was like the space that it was
that you experienced it in
so yeah i played this game on an oculus
quest
using oculus link which is basically
plugging in the headset
to a 3.1 port on a pc i mean
it ran great um one of the bigger issue
worries that i had was that i wouldn't
have enough space
however i was able to play through most
of the game seated and it worked out
pretty well when i was feeling
excited i would move my bed to the side
and play with a bit more space and i was
definitely it definitely felt more
freeing to be able to walk around a
little bit
kneel down pick things up and whatnot i
played most of it seated and
it worked it worked great for me michael
what about you
yeah i think that as i've seen vr evolve
half-life not only is it the the new
example
uh the new high bar that vr games should
be aiming for in terms of game design
it's also the new bar for uh for control
because like jake mentioned he played
most of it seated i did too
and at the time of playing the game i
had a i had a really small corner
in my apartment that i could i that was
the only space i could use
it accommodates how much space you have
it also accommodates
some of the controller limitations you
might have there is a single controller
option
so the game is designed to work if you
can only use
one controller i would imagine it's a
hard thing to work around if you want to
build a game as as detailed as
medium pushing as half-life alex but
valve pulled it off exceptionally well i
think
another thing is locomotion this is a
huge thing for me because
artificial locomotion where like for
example you push a stick forward and
your vr
character moves forward that throws me
off
big time if i do it for like longer than
five seconds
after that i'm like oh snap i'm i need
to get out of this thing
but half-life alex does a thing where
you can play with both of those things
enabled simultaneously so when i was
playing
you know if i want to uh if i want to
fit into a
explore like a tight corner but i can't
quite you know teleport to exactly where
i need to be or to get to that cabinet
high up
i would be able to use artificial
locomotion to get in the right position
and then reach
um but for navigating bigger
environments i can use teleportation
so you have access to both ways of
movement
as you play this game and i think that
that's incredibly important because you
don't have to choose between one or the
other
and i think like a lot more vr games
should uh take note of that
progress is being made and half-life
alex is an example of that
yeah i think uh like for me i live in a
studio apartment and i
i managed to play it i decided to play
the whole thing standing up and
uh also admittedly i did or may
have punched my wall a few times uh
whether it was
yeah whether it was from like complete
stricken fear
or me like shooting around the corner uh
at one combine
pulling a grenade out of the air and
tossing it in the other direction and
just i'm
smashing my fist with all those marks on
my wall uh because of that
that was a fault of me be like trying to
be like i want to do the standing up i
want to be full force this is my first
vr experience because otherwise all my
vr experiences leading up to this
um have been like smaller games and a
lot of them
are honestly made me sick or i found
really gimmicky
and not and i was kind of skeptical of
the entire medium at this point being
like
i'll just have to wait and see where
this goes years from now
but after playing this game my
skepticism is gone
like i like it's like i'm all i'm
so unbelievably all into the point where
like i've said this many times but i
think it like i think it's ruined me
one flat
there's one last thing that we need to
talk about so we're not gonna spoil
anything for any of those who are
watching this who hasn't played it but
it's important that we do talk about
the final act of this game which we've
talked a lot about what it's done for
the
medium we've talked a lot about what
half-life has done just
for games in general but this ending the
ending of this game
kind of does a little more uh that it's
it's hard to explain but i but it
recontextualizes
the entire franchise i think it
completely repositions everything we've
we've played it we've played and seen in
these games and puts it in a different
light so jake you are enough
you were not familiar with half-life
prior this or at least you were like not
someone like maybe like michael and i
who love the franchise
tell me about that experience because i
have my own kind of reaction to that
whole thing but i really want to hear
from you and like how that kind of
meshed and molded your entire experience
in the game yeah so i played through
black mesa half-life 2 half-life 2
episode 1 and half-life episode 2.
probably march so the month half-life
alex came out i was
running through all those games because
i was very excited for alex as someone
who's
into vr but i wanted to know you know
what happens at least generally and i
think
as someone who wasn't super invested in
half-life beforehand
those final moments hit really hard
even though i didn't have a lot of
context or at least i wasn't waiting
for a half-life game for 13 years like
some people were
but i think as as i guess sort of an
outsider i think what they ultimately
did is really smart
because like like you guys said it
re-contextualizes things
rather than just straight up starts
answering questions that people have
been wondering for a long time or even
just kind of
continue right where things left off i i
think
half-life alex does a very good job of
saying like
we are going to honor what happened in
these older games they are still very
important to the story
but we want you to know that what what
you've experienced what you thought
half-life was
isn't necessarily what's going to happen
going forward
and it makes me super excited to see
what half-life 3 dare i even say that
will look like in
a couple years a couple decades who
knows
this will set a couple years i would
assume that we're just uh just assuming
you're not gonna get it
that's kind of where i'm at right now
and i'd be okay with that
no i wouldn't i really want more
michael the floor is yours
if we're going to talk about how it
concludes without spoiling it
i will say that you know that last
that last chapter that last hour kind of
brings it all together
and it you know half-life alex does a
thing where
the entire game takes place in one one
day
and it's through the eyes of alex who is
i i also say in my review that i think
alex is one of the stronger
personalities in the half-life universe
but i'm really
glad that there this game centers around
her and her relationship with her father
and the the events that had unfolded
around that
um but and throughout the game i was
kind of like okay what is this leading
into what are we actually working
towards
like a lot of exciting things that
happen throughout the story
but i was kind of wondering in my mind
okay like where's
what's what's the conclusion how is it
gonna conclude in a
in a strong way and that chapter
exceeds that that expectation uh with a
very
very powerful ending for those who have
played half-life
games and because it creates
like y'all said it creates this this
this thing where
half-life can it can be much more than
what we thought it could
have been 13 years ago that's not an
easy thing to pull off
and half of alex does that i think
that's all i'll say about that because
otherwise
uh those who might be hyped up to
actually make the jump
to play this game i think that that's as
much as i want to lead them on
to say that the conclusion of this game
is
it's it's well worth it uh
the game itself is is incredibly fun and
exciting to play through but once you
make it to the
conclusion is i think when you really
truly realize
that this is game of the year material
and
why i also think it's all it's up there
with you know when you think of
games of a generation
i don't want to just regurgitate what we
all kind of
have said over and over and over again
but
jake there was one time you were telling
we were talking about this whole thing
and you had this amazing thing about
its place in in your steam library uh
tell me about that because i love it
yeah i mean i think it's hard
to see as of now half-life alex
is difficult to play you need you need
equipment
you need you need money you need a pc
and whatnot but
i think it's worth pointing out that in
five ten years from now
when it's when when vr is more
accessible
this game will be in everyone's library
i think to some extent
because you look at half-life 2 you look
at
team fortress and a bunch of other valve
games rarely do you ever see someone
steam library and they don't have those
games and i anticipate half-life alex
will
be something similar so so i think
that's all to say
that as more people get their hands on
this game i think more people will start
to understand
its impact and some of that can be a bit
difficult to see
because i okay because you know you know
the game sold well for a vr
game but it's not everyone could play it
yet and i and i think it's still kind of
waiting for its
time in the sun which hopefully happens
sooner rather than later yeah it'll i
think it'll surely
be a big thing for me and what defines
the game of the year is is
at least what i perceive something to
have like almost an immediate legacy
uh simply put i will never have this
experience
ever again period like that's it i won't
ever be able to have again not until
maybe
you know somebody comes along and out
does it but even then it's like i will
always have had
that eureka moment in half-life alex
in vr in this place so
that's it that that is that is us
telling you why game spots game of the
year is
half-life alex all right michael hyam
jake decker
i'm curtin davina thanks folks thanks
for coming by thanks for
indulging now do your best to try and
maybe consider
playing the game you should okay all
right see ya
total wasted grenade
agreed
you